what's going on everybody Ian heart is
here on behalf of PFF welcome to be our
fantasy great show ahead of us today but
first I want to go through some key
injury Roundup news because this league
always has something going on first up
Arizona Cardinals wide receiver Marquis
Brown unfortunately has been placed on
the IR with that foot injury it is not
perceived to be of the season ending
variety which is good news based on that
first initial diagnosis but for the time
being DeAndre Hopkins rondeo Moore and
probably AJ Green slash Robbie Anderson
going to be the main weapons at Kyler
Murray's disposal Damon Harris Patriots
rb1 I know all of you want to say rv2
but the man has been the starter is back
practicing in full with that hamstring
injury so look it's still going to be
remind Ray Stevens season I get it he is
not the same level of must start option
though when Damon Harris is in the
picture and just to put a little bit of
respect on Damon Harris's name guys out
of all the running backs this year with
at least 25 carries Damon Harris is the
only one averaging over two yards after
contact on at least 80 percent of his
Rush attempts so ramondre Stevenson very
good running back in his own right just
realized in week one with his whole
backfield healthy they liked using
ramandre and they definitely liked using
Damien Harrison even Ty Montgomery as
well keep that adjusted volume fresh in
your minds Jalen waddle DeAndre Swift
both limited to start this week and
again on Thursday keep an eye on it
particularly with waddle playing the
Steelers on Sunday Night Football always
got to have emergency plans in place for
those Prime Time games Darren Waller
said he will likely miss week seven in
his backup Boston Moreau with that knee
injury also isn't guaranteed to suit up
so unfortunately if you do have Darren
Waller maybe you know you have Dallas
God or on by two you're gonna have to go
to the waiver wire man I suggest Hayden
Hurst Bengals 10 M1 if he does happen to
be available just continues to be set up
with fantasy friendly scoring
opportunities as long as Joe burrow
keeps slinging that rock Jonathan Taylor
back to practicing in full with that
ankle injury and thank God hopefully
that Colts offensive line can take a
step up though guys right now he PFS
25th ranked offensive line and run
blocking grade this unit that has been
top 10 every single year since Frank
Reich has taken over that job just
realized Jonathan Taylor can't do
everything out there there are 11 guys
on offense and some of his inefficiency
struggles obviously haven't been due to
him hopefully he is healthy enough to
get going here ASAP and finally Mark
Andrews alongside JK Dobbins both not
practicing with a knee injury so with
Andrews if he's out there are not many
tight ends in the league you can just
pull the next guy up and expect them to
give us anything close to the production
and I'm not comparing Isaiah likely to
Mark Andrews but this is a guy took over
the preseason the Ravens love them
they've kept him pretty involved in the
offense anyway look I would not rank
Isaiah likely second behind Travis
Kelsey like I have Mark Andrews rank
right now still would be tough to keep
too far outside of the top 10 or 12 but
with that everyone let's get into the
main event this is BR Fantasy Live
presented by State Farm we have a
fantastic show on tap for you guys today
gonna take a quick little kind of reset
we're going to look at the top 10
fantasy performers at quarterback
running back wide receiver and tight end
through these first six weeks and try to
look at the future what they're going to
do in the next six 12 weeks is this
performance real or is it fake and we're
gonna start things off at quarterback so
looking at the top 10
top six quarterbacks really not too much
of a surprise here Josh Allen Lamar
Jackson Jalen hurts Patrick Mahomes Joe
burrow and Kyla Murray the only guy that
we're seeing not in there that was
drafted to be in there was Justin
Herbert comes in as the qb8 Geno Smith
though at qb7 Trevor Lawrence at qb9 and
Carson Wentz unfortunately injured right
now but still a nice little start to him
at least in terms of Fantasy Point
scored so I want to first start on Kyla
Murray here and guys I do think that
this Thursday night game maybe just
maybe we finally see the best version of
this Cardinals offense because it has
been out there for about half the games
not half the games half at the time in a
game this year the Cardinals offense in
terms of EPA per play which in my
opinion is about the best metric you can
use just to measure an overall group's
efficiency they're 31st in the her in
the first half they are the number one
offense in the league in the EPA per
play in the second half so with Kyler
and Cliff and Company that's what's made
this experience so frustrating and you
can see Kyler is the qb6 in fantasy you
don't get to be the QP sex and fantasy
if you've been nothing but low this year
he has had a lot of highs mixed in there
despite having to play with a bunch of
backup wide receivers really since week
one I mean okay Marquis Brown sucks that
he got hurt he was having a fantastic
year really was a bright spot for them
with that said guys remember Greg
Deutsch the Greg George era we had going
on there for a few weeks Rondell Moore
just got back in the picture DeAndre
Hopkins is finally back tonight even
Antoine Wesley someone that was supposed
to really challenge the old man AJ Green
for that other starting job he's been on
IR since week one so really hasn't been
a picture-perfect situation for Kyler
and yet here he is still in the top six
ran for 100 yards last week we've seen
those early season concerns about his
Rush attempts going down really
alleviated here over the past three
weeks I know I know the new Call of Duty
comes out in a couple weeks there is a
chance that collar is not going to be
the same player after that as guys put
his time in but guys overall based on
him getting Hopkins back based on
rondelle being there and just based on
the fact that this has been a really
good offense in the second half and I'm
confident as the season goes on they can
start getting some of that goodness in
the first 30 minutes I do believe Kyla
Murray on Pace to rack up 108 Rush
attempts this year is real
as a top six quarterback of course hey
we got to keep it high there you know
Geno Smith qb7 this year with the
upstart Seattle Seahawks this is another
player where it's tough to really assess
guys but I would keep in mind it's not
like Geno Smith has spent the last half
decade just sucking he hasn't been
playing football and because of that we
assume that he wasn't good enough to be
out there but from 2017 to 2021 Geno
Smith was the backup for Eli Manning and
then Philip Rivers and then Russell
Wilson three players that even if he was
playing better than it would just be
tough to bench him that's literally what
happened with Eli Manning in New York if
you guys remember old end of career Eli
Manning okay like he wasn't good at that
point when Ben McAdoo ended that streak
and put Gino Smith in there hey it was
just an outrage for the media but maybe
Ben was on to something four years
earlier than the Seahawks ended up being
and at this point I just don't know how
to address Geno other than as the top 10
quarterback that he has been this year
pick a stat any stat yards per attempt
he ranks fifth quarterback rating third
adjust the completion rate fourth maybe
a fan of the lovely Folks at PFF I am he
is second in PFF passing grade behind
only Josh Allen and look he's seventh in
fantasy points how long does Geno Smith
need to do this how long does every
single number need to say he's a top 10
quarterback before at least for the year
2022 we admit that he is a top 10
quarterback at least in Fantasyland guys
based on having DK Metcalf Tyler Lockett
Kenneth Walker that 30th ranked scoring
defense that's going to continue to
force them in the shootouts I do believe
that Geno Smith's standing as a top 12
fantasy quarterback is very much real
appreciate you guys over there in the
chat gonna continue to get to plenty of
your questions throughout this show
first up from SB Hopkins or Aman Ross St
Brown this week feel like Kyler will
pick it back up this week it's a great
problem to have but look I'm on Ross St
Brown if you just look at his last nine
games the guy has not missed six plus
catches every single time and no I'm not
counting his game in week four where he
just was so limited that he only played
about 30 percent of the offensive snap
so for me a Monroe is an upside wide
receiver one DeAndre Hopkins until we're
completely sure that he's going to be
getting that workload that his talents
deserve more so a top 15 option but your
roster better be pretty stacked to keep
DeAndre out of that I would really be
curious to see what those other wide
receivers are making that the choice in
the first place from DJ jettison
Cardinals been so trashed lately I feel
like I still can't trust Kyler that's my
point though man they have been trash
and the man is still the qb6 in fantasy
when you have these dual threat
quarterbacks it's similar to like the
Christian McCaffrey's album kamaras
those receiving running backs of the
world it is so hard for your Matthew
Staffordshire Tom Brady's or Joe Burrows
and Company to compete with a
quarterback that just has an entirely
second separate means of getting
production with their legs now I see Joe
burrow is in front of collar it can
happen but the floor for Kyler is so
high and that's what we're seeing right
now even if that tantalizing ceiling
which basically is Josh Allen every
single week these days doesn't quite
come to fruition
from Brian supsy Gino or Dak if he comes
back this week it is close but I'm
giving Dak the narrow narrow Edge over
it as much as I would love to wait on
Dak a week just to make sure that thumb
and everything is right this is the
matchup to Target DAC I mean we're
facing the 32nd ranked Detroit Lions
defense and right now just in terms of
implied points and all implied points
are you know as you guys know every game
has a game total you're over under and
you're spread if you take those numbers
you can actually see who Vegas is
expected to win and by how much
obviously with those points so this week
only the Chargers are implied to score
more points in Dak Prescott and the
Dallas Cowboys I do think Golf and
Company can keep Pace enough to force
the acting company to keep their foot
down on that gas pedal I have Dak
Prescott as my overall qb7 ahead of week
seven one more quarterback discussion
here guys I do think that Trevor
Lawrence still has some questions I was
honestly kind of surprised to see him in
this top 10 to begin with he has gotten
a little bit of help from some good old
rushing upside and hey Kyler I don't
think Trevor is going to be quite on
that level of volume here anytime soon
as a rusher but obviously the fact that
Lawrence can do this to an extent and I
know he can do it guys I'm a Columbus
Ohio ride and die for my life go
Buckeyes and I still have nightmares
about that dude running 60 yards you
know straight through the heart of that
Buckeye defense back in 2019 so he can
do it but as we know this is not someone
that's going to be routinely leaned on
in the same you know situation as
someone like a collar like a Lamar
Jackson like a Joan hurt so with that I
do think a standing's a little fluky he
got the two rushing touchdowns last week
and it's disguising that is the fact
that he only has one passing touchdown
over these past two weeks of action so
in the first three weeks it really did
look like Trevor Lawrence might be on to
something taking that heralded Joe
burrow you know second season asleep but
this Jaguars offense has had more
problems than answers over these past
three four weeks of action so with
Trevor Lawrence I while I do think the
gap between him cousins cars Stafford
obviously we can see that you know
looking at where they were drafted
versus they are now I don't think that
Lawrence deserves to be that far ahead
of him all the numbers I just listed for
Geno Smith again he was top 10 top five
and most of those don't they go the
other way for Trevor Lawrence 19th and
yards for a 10th 14th and QB rating 25th
and PFF passing grade so with that
everyone as much as I still think the
future is bright enough for Trevor
Lawrence I will have to say his standing
as a top 10 fantasy quarterback right
now is very much fake
all right guys top 10 running backs now
so far through six weeks of the Season
again this is full PPR scoring and
overall so sorry that you know the
running backs that had a Buy in week
five looking at you Derek Henry are
getting dinged a little bit for this but
anyway we have our top five Austin
ecklers saquon Barkley Nick Chubb
Christian McCaffrey and Leonard
fournette mixture of awesome real life
running backs getting fantasy friendly
workloads each and every week now six
through ten briefs Hall Josh Jacobs
Derek Henry Dalvin cook and ramondre
Stevenson we're going to focus on those
three names that really stick out there
and the guys that we had not expected to
be there back when we all drafted our
teams in August and early December so
first of all Bruce Hall look guys it's
been a nice start to the season for
Breeze Hall even though the true volume
takeover didn't come until week five
this was a situation where really with
Joe Flacco under Center to start Bruce
Hall was you know making chicken salad
as the expression goes out of a
situation where he just didn't have too
much there for him it's because the guy
is explosive and most important
importantly as we just talked about
these dual threat players he can catch
this year only Derrick Henry
surprisingly and Bruce Hall have
averaged over two yards per out run
among all running backs with at least 15
targets so really he's been able to go
out there and just get the sort of
workload that we want to see with
expecting a running back to keep on
keeping on as a top 10 asset right now
rb9 and expected PPR points per game
tied with Jonathan Taylor that's
expected he's even been better than that
in terms of realized points but it's not
that crazy thing it can continue because
again that workload is already there you
add it all together guys and there are
three running backs that have had top 24
finishes in every single week this
season Christian McCaffrey saquon
Barkley and yes Jets rookie running back
Breece Hall so I do believe very much so
that Brisas Hall priest Hall is standing
as an upside rb1 is real
foreign
polish Hammer with the breeze taking
over should I trade Michael Carter feels
like he sneaks a touchdown in there
often we did get the game two weeks ago
my goodness Breece Hall he had two
catches for a hundred yards and both of
those catches ended with him on the one
yard line and then Michael Carter had to
come in and vulture him it should be
illegal for an offense to take their
starting running back off the field on
first down after this got them down to
the one yard line but alas again with
Breeze Hall he does have enough of that
workload so I don't think Michael Carter
is going to be a factor if you can trade
Michael Carter for something and a deal
that's fine honestly if you're in a
deeper League I don't think Carter is
someone that needs to be rostered
necessarily all over the place with that
said Michael Carter we did see him as a
rookie got to play over 70 percent of
the Jets offensive snaps on three
separate occasions so this Workhorse
role that Bruce Hall has Once Upon a
Time all the way back in 2021 Michael
Carter did have that for a little bit as
well so I know Michael Carter isn't
someone we can feel confident about
putting in a starting lineup right now
but just one injury away from
potentially being on the cover of every
waiver wire article out there and from
Spike would I trade Josh Jacobs for AJ
Brown I have Higgins and Colton Sutton
takes us right into our next discussion
on Josh Jacobs and right now ma'am I am
leaning towards no with that I would be
curious what your other running backs
are but I am not thinking that Josh
Jacobs is about to turn to a pumpkin and
start being the guy that we saw during
the first three years of his career
again because his workload has been that
much different this year so he has
caught at least five passes in three
straight games guys first 45 games of
his career he only did that five times
so with Josh McDaniels come to Las Vegas
personally the reason why I didn't have
Josh Jacob strength higher in the
preseason I thought this was going to
look a lot like New England Southwest
where we just don't know what it's going
to be we just know it's going to be
muddled complicated 3-4 running backs
during any given week then we had the
Hall of Fame game where Josh Jacob's
getting a lot of run is he going to be
traded oh they drafted zamir white okay
all that happened and guess what here we
stand in week seven and Josh Jacobs is
the clear lead featured three down
running back in this offense they do
keep Brandon Bolden involved just a
little bit on some pass downs but again
we don't need a ton of passed down usage
when we're still getting enough to get
five catches per game you know as much
as I would love for our fantasy running
backs to be out there getting 100 of the
snaps it's not realistic and just to see
Josh Jacobs consistently clearing 80
snaps it's an advantage that we've never
seen him have so far throughout his NFL
career and with this sort of workload
we're seeing Josh Jacobs just take
advantage of his own god-given talents I
mean pick a stat any stat for this guy
you're gonna see he's one of the best
running backs in the league PFF Russian
grade first among 39 running backs at
least 50 carries you might say Ian it's
PFF we don't believe in PFF I wish you
would but with that said yours per carry
seventh yards after contact for carry
third missed tackles Force per carry
third Josh Jacobs has the exact same
Advanced analytics basically that
everyone and their mother was freaking
out about what Javonte Williams this
time last year so I do think Josh Jacobs
as much as the past hurts we do need to
look ahead for the future and I think
that Josh Jacobs standing as an upside
rb1 is very much real
from Weber should I trust Eno tonight
feel like that Saints defense would
Hound him it all depends off James
Connor is going to try to gut this one
out or not last week you know Benjamin
one of only three running backs to play
on over 85 percent of their offensive
snaps so when you have that sort of
usage it's just impossible to sit the
man it's the same thing with why we were
you know trotton ramandre Stevenson out
there and warning him in just a minute
but guys when you get that much usage
it's just going to be really hard to
rank him outside the top 15 top 16
running backs so since defense is a
little bit banged up right now more so
they're secondary I would start you know
Benjamin fantasy lineups of far most
shapes and sizes should Conor be ruled
out and from King kuzma I feel like
Stevenson is going to go off this week
let's talk more about Madre Stevenson I
want to be clear with this verse he's
playing really well and he has earned
the right to be the lead running back in
this offense whether he will be the rest
away or not PFF seventh highest grade
rusher on the season 10 the Euros for
carry 7th and yards after contact for
Kerry he's been doing enough good things
as a receiver over as well two touchdown
game last week could have even been
three he got stuffed on the goal line
twice in there but a lot of things
needed to happen for Stevenson to get to
this point similar to Kenneth Walker you
can be a great player but just not have
a great workload because there's other
players in your offense that are going
to be featured so in Stevenson's case
guys
week one comes along Damon Harris was
his starting running back ramandre
Stevenson played the third most snaps in
that backfield in week one because even
Ty Montgomery already had the lead pass
down rule so Ty Montgomery is still on
IR with that ankle injury he is out of
the picture we don't need to worry about
him for the time being Damon Harrison on
the other hand he practiced in full on
Thursday with that hamstring injury does
seem to be on the verge of returning so
Stevenson isn't someone that's gonna all
of a sudden be this you know recommended
set you can't play them no matter what
not even if there's a fire I'm not
saying that where Madre Stevenson but
guys it's a game of volume and let's
face it this is Patriots offense going
to continue scoring 28 points per game
with Bailey zappy or a band-up version
of Mac Jones under Center maybe but I
wouldn't say it's exactly a guarantee
we're not talking about you know a chief
sort of offensive environment here and
just adding one running back and Damon
Harris back in the puzzle all of a
sudden Stephenson getting all those
opportunities at the goal line that is
all at a lot of risks so while Stevenson
is still someone that's going to give
you a lot of good weeks down the road
now I do think he will finish as a top
20 maybe even top 15 running back I do
believe his standing as a top 10 fantasy
running back because of the volume he's
about to get down the stretch is very
much fake
all right Sports genius what do I think
about Hopkins today worth the start
again I have Hopkins as I believe I can
pull it up right now oh he's catch my
rankings on the PFF app I have DeAndre
Hawkins as my wide receiver 17. so I
have him behind guys like Amari Cooper
Tyler Lockett Chris olave Mike Evans I
am playing Hopkins ahead of guys like
Christian Kirk Brandon Cooks Terry
McLaren among others so the thing with
Hopkins I think we're slightly
exaggerating you know what the fall off
was like last year I get it you drafted
him last year to be this top five top
six wide receiver and he wasn't and it's
annoying when that happens still though
in weeks one through seven before he
initially suffered that hamstring injury
against the Packers the overall wide
receiver 12 and you might say Ian well
some teams have buys during that stretch
good call Smart job by you still the
wide receiver 17 though even if we go
PPR points per game on a per game basis
so even at the days of Hopkins going out
there getting 190 Targets in a season
and being the overall wide receiver one
or over I still think Hopkins in an
offense now that needs him to try to be
as close to that guy as possible with
Marquis Brown out of the picture
definitely for this next month or two
DeAndre Hopkins upside wide receiver two
at worst should be started in the heavy
majority of fantasy lineups and from
Evan you fade waddle this week we'll get
right to that here with our wide
receiver discussion quickly looking at
the big top 10 Cooper cup number one we
talked all off season about who this
year's Cooper cup was going to be turns
out is once again Cooper cup behind him
some familiar faces Stefan Diggs Tyree
kill Justin Jefferson Jamar Chase and
Marquis Brown again can't overstate just
how well Marquis Brown was playing truly
the one brightest Ray of sunlight in
that Cardinals offense sucks that he had
to suffer that injury
in the back half of the top ten we do
have Jalen waddle at number seven
Devonte Adams at eight AJ brownout nine
and Debo Samuel at 10. so gonna focus on
three of those four ladder players here
first up with Jalen waddle so this week
I is unique because he is dealing with
that shoulder injury right now Mike
McDaniel did say he's optimistical suit
up but you need to have a backup plan
for Jalen waddle purely because the
Dolphins play the Steelers on Sunday
Night Football so I don't want to
restrict you guys you know to only
having to pick between a Steeler a
dolphin a bear or a patriot once you
know you're trying to win that game at
the end so have a backup plan if at all
possible with JLM waddle if you happen
to have like multiple top 20 wide
receivers if it's between Hopkins and
Jalen waddle like this would be a
situation where I probably would give
the nod to Hopkins because there's
enough concern about waddle being out
out of times thought that's really going
to put your fantasy line up in a bad
position if you don't make that move but
just this year with Jalen waddle it's
one of those things where he has
obviously shown off his incredible
Talent just some of the big plays he's
been able to make to yards after the
catch my God you know just even if you
never watch football before I think it's
pretty clear you can identify the two
fastest players on the field during any
Dolphins game and they both happen to
wear you know aqua and play wide
receiver for that Squad so this year the
Dolphins first in shift motion rate they
have had Tua out there Teddy out there
Skyler Thompson out there and guess what
they are second in the league and yards
per attempt still their eighth and
overall QB rating which isn't the best
stat for a specific QB but can't tell
you how good an overall passing game
environment is even 10th and EPA per
pass place so with Jalen waddle
we know the talents there the big
questions for him coming in this year
were okay is he going to have enough
volume behind Tyrique and is this
offense going to be good enough to
enable two high-end fantasy wide
receivers well we've checked that
offensive Mark again Tyree kill and
Jalen waddle first pair of teammates in
NFL history back in that Ravens game to
each have 10 catches 150 plus yards and
two receiving touchdowns in the same
game and the target share because Mike
McDaniel has been so willing to put the
overall majority of this offense in
these guys hands that's why we haven't
seen a consistent running back or a
consistent Mike to Sicky out there it's
been okay Tyreek Hill is getting all of
his and there's still room for Jalen
waddle he has a higher Target share than
guys like Michael Pittman and a Monroe
Saint Brown even higher area share than
someone like Debo Samos so Jalen waddle
status as an upside wide receiver one I
do believe is very much real
from at almenci can Adam stay consistent
this year we're going to talk about that
right now my friend this has objectively
been the worst version of Devonte Adams
in about five years now I do say
relative he is still very much
incredible again he is eighth in PPR
points right now so I don't think that
Devonte Adams has gone anywhere in terms
of being one of the game's Elite but we
do need to take a little bit of a step
back and just look at what the 2022
edition of Devonte Adams is in terms of
yards Perot run he's at 2.07 last year
2.82 2.96 before that that is his lowest
Mark in at least five years he's getting
targeted on 25 percent of his 25 of his
routes run with Aaron Rodgers over the
past two years that was over 30 percent
we have seen these games particularly
against Byron Murphy and the Cardinals
and even last week where yeah he hit the
big plays but we just weren't seeing
them pepper over targets have not seen
Derek Carr force feed the ball to
Devonte Adams in the same manner as
Aaron Rodgers now Aaron Rodgers didn't
have a Darren Waller didn't have a
hunter renfrod also throw to but you
know fantasy managers were selfish we
still want all those targets anyway and
even the PFF receiving grade 78.2 after
finishing each of the last two seasons
well above 90 and two seasons before
that well above 80. so I don't think
it's all on Devonte by any stretch of
the imagination if you guys want to go
and do one of those blind player
comparisons player a versus player B
you'd be really disappointed when I show
you that Derek Carr has had awfully
similar passing numbers to Zach Wilson
this season and as much as I do still
think maybe Zach Wilson could work out
that was not a compliment to Zach Wilson
so we do have Darren Waller probably
going to be out here at least this week
and maybe more with that hamstring
injury that could condense things more
to Devonte Adams but I do think and this
is kind of the tricky part of this
he's still a top eight wide receiver
with all this so I don't think Devonte
Adams is going anywhere from this spot
which on the one hand no I don't think
we're going to see Devonte Adams
overtake a Tyree kill overtake of Stefan
Diggs and go back to being that top five
option we have seen his offense and him
being Devonte Adams being the one group
with these new wide receivers not really
going out of their way to force feed
their new shiny toy in town I do think
that Devonte Adams still very much a top
10 fantasy wide receiver and I do
believe it is going to be a case where
he is a little bit closer to 10 than one
than in past years that's fine still
someone you're starting regardless of
the matchup but maybe just Dash those
expectations just a little bit Devonte
Adams status as the wide receiver eight
in fantasy very much real
foreign
AJ Brown the wide receiver 10 Debo and
we got Greg Smith saying in the chat
that he's wondering if he should fade or
trade Debo he's been interesting this
year and he has been interested in this
year Greg and I actually came on the you
know we had a couple pre-season uh
streams here with BR fantasy that I was
lucky enough to come on and talk and
Debo was one of my Fades and hey the
guys wide receiver 10 this year so not
like that's working out too great so far
Ian but my big issue with Debo was just
the fact that with his workload as this
running running back wide receiver
hybrid he was going to have to continue
to be like by far the best player in the
NFL with the ball in his hands in order
to make up for not having the same sort
of targets and opportunities as guys
like Stefon Diggs like Jamar Chase and
guys that are just again they have that
higher volume floor they don't have to
make up for it with this asinine
efficiency as often as Debo and that
really has come to fruition so far this
year last year he averaged 15 expected
PPR points per game this year he's
averaging 15.9 expected PPR points per
game so his workload is actually a
little bit better than last year the
difference guys last year he was at 21.1
PPR points scored per game this year
just 15.5 so we haven't seen Debo
function as the League's best running
back basically this year that's been the
major problem he hasn't gained more than
12 rushing yards he has not gained more
than 12 rushing yards people since week
two hasn't found the end zones of Russia
since week one and when everyone in this
passing game is healthy and George
Kittle Brandon ayok and Debo Samuel as
we saw last week with all three of those
guys catching eight passes the 49ers
don't feel the need to go out of their
way to get Debo more targets than the
other guys and hey to be fair nor should
they George Kittle is incredible in his
own right Brandon Iver scored two
touchdowns last week so
don't hate the player hate the workload
I am not a big fan of Devo Stamos
workload and for that reason I do
believe his status as a top 10 fantasy
wide receiver is fake
from DJ jettison appreciate you always
coming on with us DJ and the joku or
Hawkinson this week I am going to be
leaning towards the upstart Brown's
tight end David najoku just barely in
that Starship decision we do see the
guys basically right next to each other
in that same group though with the
season long rankings top 10 tight ends
through six weeks of action Travis
Kelsey Mark Andrews zackers Dallas
Goddard David najoku TJ Hawkinson Tyler
Higby Gerald Everett taysom Hill what a
time to be alive and at Robert tuned in
closing things out at Titan 10 but with
Dave and the Joker let's start off with
him he's been incredible guys just these
Advanced analytics behind them
absolutely Preposterous third yards per
route run fourth in yards per reception
third in PFF receiving great behind only
Travis Kelsey and Mark Andrews so Jacoby
Brissette experience you know hasn't
been wonderful I don't think we've
gotten a game over 250 passing yards
just yet no games with three plus
passing touchdowns it has not gone great
we've seen him get more and more
mediocre as a year went on that game
against the Patriots last week was a new
low and the joku has still managed to
keep on keeping on because he's been
able to overcome the lackluster play
Under uh sometimes under center with his
own efficiency and just finally getting
that featured every down roll and a
Browns offense that hey when they paid
Austin Hooper 50 plus million or maybe
it was 48 you guys know what I'm saying
when they paid Hooper that much they
weren't willing to still give him that
future role they kept in the Joker they
kept Harris and Brian involved it has
been far more than Dave and the Joker
show this year so again the clear-cut
number two in the passing game behind
Amari Cooper the thing with the joker
too guys look he's got about five more
games here playing without DeSean Watson
but it's gonna be really tough to keep
him out of the three spot once Watson is
back under Center for that stretch run
so because in the Joker has proven to be
able to operate at a top three level in
efficiency even before he gets a massive
quarterback upgrade I do believe his
standing as a top five fantasy tight end
is very much real
foreign
Tyler Higby on him the waiver is he
worth the pickup as always at the pens
unfortunately I can't look at each and
every one of you guys individual teams
and make the direct decision probably
though if you're someone that's been out
there not able to get a consistent tight
end that's fine I do think Higby can
still settle in as this you know
consistent top 12 tight end that he's
been so far I'm not so sure we're going
to see him continue to be this tight end
seven all season long though just taking
a step back and looking at this Rams
offense we've seen this before guys we
have seen a five six game stretch of
Tyler Higby Going Bonkers specifically
it happened at the end of that 2020
season it's what made the guy such a
highly touted tight end going into last
season and what happened they didn't
need him last year they had Cooper cup
they had Robert Woods then they had
Odell Beckham Jr and they won a Super
Bowl so it worked out just fine for Los
Angeles the last six games of 2020 that
was actually when Cooper cup was getting
injured that's when they weren't able to
get too much out of Robert Woods that's
when Jared Goff was on his last
basically stand with the ram fans and
that's when Higby really started to have
these Gronk s numbers out there and got
his name so big in the fancy highlights
in the first place so with Higby it is
pure pure pure volume he does not check
the sort of boxes you want to see in
terms of efficiency in terms of talent
and still an offense that I do believe
would rather go through its wide
receivers more than they have to this
point so I do think Tyler Higby if he
was having all the success in the Rams
offense was killing it yeah why would
they go away from him but he's having
all this success because of raw volume
in an offense that ranks 25th end points
per game so nice if you've had him these
first six seven weeks and I don't think
he's going to fall off the face of the
Earth he still isn't every down player
out to position but I do think Tyler
Higby standing as a top eight fantasy
football tight end is fake
all right guys fun going over some real
Fable let's jump into personalized
fantasy advice presented by State Farm
where the personal price plan is all
about creating a price just for you now
is the time to get going in the chat
everyone starting off from busy Bank
what do you trade at Jalen waddle for
Joe Mixon I think that is a very fair
trade especially if you're already good
enough at wide receiver which I'm
guessing you are being willing to trade
Jalen waddle in the first place so again
Joe Mixon number one in expected PPR
points per game among all running backs
this year I think he's only scratching
the surface of the sort of fantasy
ceiling we're going to see down the
stretch what did you drop Melvin Gordon
don't drop him just yet we do have
Nathaniel Hackett coming out and saying
that he is going to get to start this
week my question with Melvin Gordon is
like what's that start even mean because
Javonte Williams was starting before he
got injured and even Javonte Williams
wasn't getting a 50 snap rate
unfortunately even if Melvin Gordon has
the most of the load in this three
running back committee it's not that the
Broncos offense has been bad guys they
have been the single worst offense in
the League this year in points per game
one freaking game with more than 16
points just not the situation we want to
Target so Melvin Gordon you don't need
to keep them I would try to get it for
one more week though see if this
backfield finally stabilizes all right
trade rumors I could see happening so we
do need to kind of keep an eye on this
Chase Claypool situation I'm not so sure
why the Steelers are in this spot where
they have a Young quarterback and Kenny
Pickett and Chase Claypool as much as
people can stay mad about him you know
celebrating the first down last year or
calling himself a top three wide
receiver during the off season be mad
about those things if you want but Chase
Claypool didn't score 13 touchdowns as a
rookie by accident and we saw lastly
with us 96 yards in a touchdown that he
is still someone that can play ball with
that said guys if Chase Chase Claypool
does get traded God forbid to the Green
Bay Packers he is going to be someone
immediately taking major leaps off the
fantasy football rankings with his
ability to go up make the contested
catches and just even get scheme the
ball don't don't forget guys as a rookie
they legit gave this dude Rush attempts
more weeks than not and even in week one
this year he was up there actually
buying for Naji Harris's overall lead I
mean Claypool inexplicably had five or
six Rush attempts in that game so it'd
be good for Claypool because right now
he's being treated as a fairly clear-cut
option in this offense and it would
allow even more targets to go to Deontay
Johnson and George Pickens so again I
don't know why the Steelers like they
don't need to get rid of Chase Claypool
Financial or anything like that doesn't
seem like he's been that much of a
locker room problem you know taken well
he took a dip from gunner in the locker
room is that a big problem so I don't
know why the Steelers would do it but in
fantasy it'd be good for all parties
involved
from SMC Derman uh DeAndre Hopkins or
taysom Hill I am going to go with
DeAndre Hopkins in this situation the
Saints getting healthier at QB might not
be so good for taysom health we do see
them start actually going back to James
even though it is leaning towards Danny
Dalton I do think we'll see Dalton out
there remember taysom hill now two
injuries away from having that full-time
quarterback role which is really going
to bring out the most of his fantasy
potential give me DeAndre Hopkins from W
Scott do you think Aaron Jones is ever
going to get going
I think better than he has been but guys
Aaron Jones it's not that he's
disappointed he's been one of the more
efficient running backs in the entire
league in terms of yards for Kerry I
think he's at 5.8 his missed tackles
forces George after contact are all
fantastic somehow without Devonte Adams
here Aaron Jones is averaging four-year
lows and receptions and receiving yards
per game that's been the shocking part
for me to do his fifth on his own team
and targets Aaron Jones this year has 23
targets AJ Dillon has 20. age J dawn has
three more Rush attempts they have the
exact same amount of Rush attempts and
targets the real alert for AJ Dylan I'm
sorry Aaron Jones this year was the hope
that he was going to get that featured
Alvin Kamara that featured Christian
McCaffrey level of Target share that
he's shown the ability to just be
efficient with in the past unfortunately
it doesn't seem to be on the table so
Jones right now I believe he's the rb18
rb19 I do think he could creep closer to
that rb1 borderline at that rb12 spot in
terms of him getting up and being his
top five top eight option without an
injury to AJ Dylan I don't think he will
from gem frame Miller which two RBS
should I start Stevenson Jeff Wilson
Zeke or Eno if James Connor is going to
be out I would go to Madre Stevenson and
Eno Benjamin pure volume play of James
Connor plays all of a sudden we not
really sure who's going to be getting
more touches between him and you know
then I would go as ramadri Stevenson and
Ezekiel Elliott honestly Zeke and Jeff
Wilson pretty similar roles right now
I'll take the guy implied for the second
most points of the week at home against
the Lions League or scoring defense
from Sean moose who should I get for
Dalvin cook need a good wide receiver I
think the Jalen waddle uh call could
honestly be something there DK Metcalf
CD lamb
Michael Pittman I think those are all
guys that are reasonable for Dalvin cook
I don't hate the idea of selling high on
Dalvin cook out here they're receiving
stuff just hasn't quite been there for
him this year he scored three touchdowns
in the last two weeks five and one
Vikings you know they have done some
good things offensively but before
Alexander Madison hurt his own shoulder
we actually were seeing a little bit
more split usage with Dalvin in that
backfield so Kevin O'Connell coming over
from La doing really good things but we
have also seen the same problem
infecting these La running backs not the
most well in coach in the world to feed
his future running back a bunch of
targets
from Seth dlbk should I drop Gibson with
Robinson taking his snaps he Gibson
unfortunately if you're in some of these
you know deeper or more shallow leaks I
should say he's not someone that needs
needs needs to be held similar with
Melvin Gordon I would like you to keep
him on there because he is only one
injury away to honestly either mckissick
or Brian Robinson from being a viable
rb2 himself as things stand right now as
Brian Robinson projected as the lead
touch getter but think about it guys
when Antonio Gibson was there without
Brian Robinson we still had a hard time
ranking him hired you know 15th or 16th
during any given week because whenever
this Washington team falls behind on the
scoreboard which has been pretty often
this year if you haven't noticed JD
mckissick takes over as the lead pass
down back so honestly if I could pick
between Robinson or mckissick getting
hurt I probably prefer mckissick just
for Gibson's own fantasy stock just so
he could then get those targets I know
we never ever want to see anyone get
hurt and I don't I wish God would turn
off injuries as well in real life but
just in this backfield when we have
three running backs in a bad offense
it's really tough to expect much of any
of them each is two not one injuries
away from getting that featured roll
from Michael Bolson Aaron Jones or
DeAndre Swift this week in half PPR it's
close I am gonna lean towards Aaron
Jones right now only because we're still
not certain if DeAndre Swift is going to
have his back to featured workload I
mean this year he has had that shoulder
and ankle injury and so far this week
back-to-back limited practices the sort
of stuff we're hearing is that he hopes
he can play not that he is going to play
not that he's back to 100 percent and
the concern for me is the fact that in
week one swift was fantastic and in week
two he met value as well but it was on
extremely limited snaps I think they
only gave him four carries we had only
like four or five targets as well he
made the most out of them but guys if we
can't even guarantee 10 combined carries
and targets for Swift all of a sudden
Aaron Jones's workload as a five and a
half Point favorite against that
Washington defense looks a lot better so
if DeAndre Swift goes into the weekend
with a questionable tag and we don't
hear anything from the coaching staff
from shefter from Rhapsody from whoever
saying that he is going to be back to
his usual workload I would lean Aaron
Jones there
I want to thank you guys for tuning in
again week seven flying by I know it's
been great getting to talk to each and
every one of you all year throughout
this on BR fantasy as always thanks for
tuning in this has been be our Fantasy
Live presented by State Farm and until
next time take care everyone